A good screenplay should have an airtight
plot, with no holes or mistakes to ruin the
audience’s appreciation of it.
But even the best screenplays go through studio
notes, re-writes, re-shoots and serious editing
before they get put in theatres, and it’s
sometimes a wonder movies make any sense at
all.
Even in some great movies, not every little
detail makes sense, and the movies on this
list are no exception.
This is Screen Rant’s list of 10 Famous
Movie Plot Holes That Need To Be Explained.
And we should warn you, there WILL be spoilers.
Star Wars
The story of the Star Wars saga goes that
once Anakin Skywalker becomes Darth Vader,
a committed crony of Emperor Palpatine, his
children are hidden away from him for their
own protection.
Leia is raised by Senator Organa on the planet
of planet of Alderaan while Luke is raised
by Anakin’s step-brother, “Uncle” Owen
on Anakin’s home planet of Tatooine.
But does that really make any sense?
The Star Wars universe is a vast and varied
place, so if Obi-Wan and Yoda really wanted
to keep Luke safe, wouldn’t they keep him
far away from Tatooine and his old family?
Wouldn’t they also change his last name
to anything but “Skywalker”?
If Darth Vader ever decided to check in on
his old family, this tactic would prove to
be an awful mistake.
Zootopia
Before the otter florist Emmitt Otterton goes
missing in Disney’s smash hit Zootopia,
his black panther chauffeur mentions that
he was yelling about the “night howlers,”
leading police rabbit Judy Hopps to assume
that he’s referring to the pack of wolves
that kidnapped him.
But later on, it’s revealed that “night
howlers” are actually toxic flower bulbs
with psychotropic effects, and that explains
why several of Zootopia’s “predators”
have been behaving aggressively.
But how did no one recognize the symptoms
of “night howlers”?
Judy’s foxy friend Gideon Grey recognizes
the flowers immediately, and they’re stocked
in the city’s flower shops, so they must
be pretty common.
Yet neither Dr. Madge Honey Badger nor anyone
else can identify the flowers or their effects
for almost the entire movie.
Toy Story
OK, we might be nitpicking about the plot
hole in this Pixar classic, but we’re going
to tell you about it anyway.
When Buzz Lightyear arrives in Andy’s room
for the first time, he is utterly unaware
that he is actually a toy, and not a space
ranger.
So why is it that when Andy enters the room,
Buzz freezes and stops moving, just like the
rest of the toys?
If Buzz doesn’t think he’s a toy, then
he shouldn’t act like one!
If he does know he’s a toy, then he’s
just lying to the other toys.
Either way, colour us confused!
The Matrix
When Neo and his pals need to enter “The
Matrix”, they have to sit down on an adapted
dentist’s chair and “plug in”, always
with a supervisor watching over them at the
computer terminal.
So how is it that Cypher -- the traitor of
the group -- is able to plug into the Matrix
and meet with the nefarious Agent Smith without
the knowledge of the others?
In an old interview, the Wachowskis claim
that, earlier in the film, Cypher set up an
automated system to enter the Matrix on his
own.
Still, it doesn’t explain the larger question
about The Matrix: Why bother “unplugging”
at all?
Red pill or not, living inside of The Matrix
certainly seems more pleasant than eating
goop and wearing rags in the “real world”.
Iron Man 3
You knew at least one Marvel movie would have
to make the list, so we’re pointing out
the most obvious plot hole in the entire MCU.
When Tony Stark finds himself in a tight spot
at the end of Iron Man 3, he initiates the
“House Party” protocol, and J.A.R.V.I.S.
summons several remote-controlled Iron Man
suits, all of which come equipped with the
same powers as Iron Man himself.
Only, why didn’t he do that before?
Like when the Mandarin attacked and destroyed
his house?
Or when he’s stuck in rural Tennessee recharging
his suit with a car battery?
If screenwriters have to rely on deus ex machina
to resolve their plots, they could at least
put a little more work into it than this.
Ocean’s Eleven
The appeal of Ocean’s Eleven is in watching
all your favorite movie stars hanging out
with each other and being their charming selves.
But if you look at the heist movie closely,
does it really make sense?
First, Danny Ocean tricks casino owner Benedict
into transferring all of his money into some
vans waiting outside (by threatening to blow
up the vault).
But then Terry Benedict has his men intercept
the vans before they get out of town, only
to find out they’re actually full of X-rated
fliers.
But: when did Ocean and his crew make the
switch?
In a DVD commentary, director Steven Soderbergh
claims there is no explanation, meaning it
was either an oversight, or we’re supposed
to believe there’s some movie magic at play.
The Lost World: Jurassic Park
At the end of this dino-blockbuster, a Tyrannausaurus
Rex makes it off the self-contained island
and wreaks havoc on the streets of San Diego.
But we have some questions about how he got
there.
When the boat containing the T-Rex docks at
the mainland, Nick boards to find that the
crew has been slaughtered, when a guard accidentally
opens the cargo hold, freeing the T-Rex into
the real world.
But if the Rex was locked in the cargo hold,
how did it kill the boat crew?
Well, in the original script, a group of velociraptors
were on board as well, and they were responsible
for the slaughter, but in the movie, it’s
a major plot hole.
The Santa Clause
Obviously, The Santa Clause takes place in
a world where Santa Claus exists.
That’s why Tim Allen gets turned into the
jolly old giftgiver when he kills the previous
Santa.
So how is it that before that fateful event,
the adults of the movie behave as though Santa
doesn’t exist?
Obviously, he’s been delivering presents
to their children every year, meaning there
is material proof that somebody is sneaking
into their house every Christmas Eve.
Why does Tim Allen have to literally transform
into ol’ Saint Nick for this to make any
sense?
Colour us confused!
Signs
In M. Night Shyamalan’s Signs, aliens invade
Earth and begin to take over.
But at the end of the movie, little Bo Hess
discovers the aliens’ weakness: water.
When a glass of water falls on an alien, it
burns its skin like acid, so the Hess family
uses H2O to fight back against the extra-terrestrials.
Only, why would the aliens invade a planet
that’s surface is 71% water?
Why would they invade a planet where rain
could come down at any time?
More importantly, when they’re running through
a dew-covered cornfield earlier in the film,
why doesn’t the water affect them?
Obviously, the twist at the end of Signs could
have used a little more thought.
Furious 7
We need to talk about The Rock.
We’re all glad that Dwayne Johnson makes
an appearance in the seventh Fast and Furious
film, but not everything his character does
makes sense.
While he’s lying in a hospital bed, wearing
a cast, Hobbs realizes he needs to help the
team, but has zero information about their
whereabouts or what they’re doing.
Nonetheless, he finds an ambulance and launches
it off a broken overpass at exactly the right
time to prevent another vehicle from killing
Lettie and Ramsay.
Then, he grabs a machine gun and somehow walks
across town, ready to help Dominic Toretto
shoot down a helicopter in his battle with
Deckard Shaw.
Not a lot of this makes sense.
But we have to admit, if you have to write
a superhuman into your script to make it make
sense, it probably helps if the superhuman
is played by The Rock.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any huge plot holes that you want
everyone to know about?
Join the discussion in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.